[Music]
lebron james quoted you he posted a
quote of yours and it's actually
something that I think has struck a
nerve with a lot of people this is from
LeBron he posted your quote there's no
talent here this is hard work this is an
obsession talent does not exist we are
all equals as human beings and then it's
all about just its dedication and time
and obsession and it's funny because
I've actually talked to a lot of young
people over the years of a setup like
I'm interested in show business I say
look we don't know what talent is but
nothing beats really hard work this is
something that means a lot to you that's
a message that means a lot yeah I truly
believe we are all equal as human beings
if we are obsessed with something and we
truly pursue our passion with everything
we have regardless of any anything else
if you are obsessed I work hard and put
in the time you will succeed and that is
a philosophy that I carry my coaches
carry on and to see LeBron James was
like a mega superstar over here and a
phenomenal phenomenal athlete share and
that belief is is inspiring right back
to me and it shows that we are thinking
correct you know this is this is hard
work this is an obsession nothing can be
hard work you have you've actually
experienced where there was a period of
your life where you were a plumber you
were a plumber and then you decided one
day I certainly didn't work hard in the
flume and game cuz I you know I wasn't
obsessed you it really worked hard you
could be a plumber right now exactly you
know if you're doing something and
you're not interested if no passion for
it you you really you should truly
follow your passion hi so what did you
do to scrap that you were working as a
plumber one day and it was one day when
you said yeah well no I mean I had many
days on site it's cold it's damp it's
dark and I'm looking around at everyone
else and it is not a good but not that
if you're passionate about that then
then that's okay but for me it just
wasn't a life I wanted to live and I was
in I remember during a lunch break I was
in the car park and I was pissing rain
down and
and I just said to myself I don't do
some music playing and I it was like
some there wasn't even words he was just
a kind of a beat and I got like real I
went somewhere where then I was like I'm
out of here I'm gonna just drive out of
this build and so I head home and and
and pursue this dream of becoming a
world champion in mixed martial arts and
that's what I did I drove home and when
I got home my mother and father said how
come you're not still at work and I said
I'm never gonna go back to that side
another day in my life and then all hell
broke loose but fight yeah I assured
them that am I was gonna go and do this
I was gonna put everything into it and
although they didn't understand that at
that time true-true hard walk through
dedication they saw what I was pursuing
and they supported me and and I I don't
I did
you